coup de filet dans les milieux néo-nazis
treize français interpellés dans
plusieurs villes de l'hexagone et un à
londres
huit personnes ont été mises en examen
pour menaces de mort et incitation à la
haine raciale
un réseau qui avait son site sur
internet et qui a été mis au jour grâce
à une collaboration franco britannique
agnès vahramian yannick aroussi et
benoît cadres et bienvenue sur le site
internet des charmeurs skins des garçons
qui distingue deux types d'hommes les
aryens et les autres qualifiés de
sous-hommes pour cela après avoir cliqué
voilà ce qui les attend ce réseau
internet été repérés depuis septembre 97
encore fallait-il y mettre des noms
l'enquète démarre en juin 96 dans ce
cimetière de toulon après des
profanations de tombes
les auteurs sont assez vite identifié il
s'agit de jeunes gens d'une vingtaine
d'années et qui se te faut et qui se
photographier dans leurs oeuvres pendant
leur arrestation
le frère de l'un d'entre eux tentent de
se débarrasser du document ils les
jettent dans ce site militaire ici près
de toulon les gendarmes les retrouve
voilà leur découverte de la littérature
satanistes mais surtout néonazis wotan
publication des champs lammer skins et
la revue 14 mo ou à la rubrique
bricolage on trouve comment fabriquer
une bombe
des revues que recevaient les
profanateurs de toulon mais il est bien
clair que ce n'est pas lui qui a écrit
ces revues on les lui a adressé les a
reçus il ne reçoit plus il en a peut
être lu quelques passages mais pour
autant partager t-il toutes les idées
question c'est la direction centrale des
renseignements généraux qui donnera aux
gendarmes le nom des auteurs de ces
revues et du réseau internet
il s'agit de deux anciens skin hervé guz
réfugié à londres
formé chez les néo nazis aux états unis
et eric monier un lyonnais féru
d'informatique fils de notable arrêté à
son domicile ici il y a quelques jours
ce groupe étaient connus des
renseignements généraux régulièrement il
proférait sur son site informatique des
menaces de mort contre simone veil anne
sinclair ou encore patrick gaubert
ancien conseiller de charles pasqua
chargé de la lutte contre le racisme
quand vous avez des gens qui
10 dans des réunions que je suis le
symbole de celui qui veut faire
disparaître les mouvements dits
nationaliste c'est comme ça qu'ils
s'appellent qui sont en fait compte des
mouvements racistes et xénophobes
vous avez des militants qui se disent eh
bien puisque nos chefs nous explique que
l'ennemi principal c'est gaubert est bon
on va agir on va le tuer comme ça on
sera continu les enquêteurs cherchent
maintenant à savoir si ce réseau
international n'aurait pas commis des
actions violentes en france